most Americans define success as being
happy at work instead of just making
more money that's one of the findings in
a new study from LinkedIn we've teamed
up with the professional networking site
for our series it's called work in
progress
look at issues facing the American
workforce only four percent of workers
say scouring a corner office is a
measure of success 60 percent believe
it's loving what I do and 34 percent say
they'd be willing to take a ten percent
pay cut if it meant they could design
their own work schedule
Catherine Fisher is LinkedIn's career
expert and joins us at the table good
morning to you thanks for having me
we're very glad you're here I want to
talk about the ten percent pay cut
because most people under any
circumstances think I want to take a cut
in pay what does this mean what do they
want to do what's fascinating is that we
spend ninety thousand hours over the
course of our lifetime working so that's
half of your waking hours of working and
we really wanted to understand what
motivates people what gets them up in
the morning really what are people in it
for and they what they told us is that
success means many different things to
different people right and so for the
Millennials they really value the
ability to travel so while they're still
motivated to have that financial
stability they also want to take some
you know different risks so that they
can do what they love which is traveling
so if it meant getting a lower salary
but allowed them to travel they would do
that as opposed to having a higher
salary not being able yeah because
that's what they value is is a means to
feeling successful and they like side
hustles I like the sound of that side
hustles means what getting another job
it's another job that's not your primary
source of income and it's not your
nine-to-five so if you're not getting
the passion that you're that you want
from your nine-to-five you know let's
say you love teaching yoga but it's not
going to help you pay your bills you do
that on this side and that's a side
hustle the cytosol sounds almost like
something that's illegal yeah Ricardo
Monti
[Laughter]
but it's just that sounds like
moonlighting isn't that is that
basically what we used to call
moonlighting let me ask you this about
the the penchant for wanting to travel
but also the finding says that people
have career FOMO that stands for fear of
missing out so they want to travel but
they're worried about missing out that
sounds like very fretful travel and
they're also not they're also not as
interested in the flashy title they'd
rather get the skills that they need to
be successful so with technology
changing so rapidly and the different
jobs associated with that changing I
think there's a fear that if you're not
up-to-date on your skills and you're not
keeping yourself open up to
opportunities you may miss the next big
thing
how did gender play it out different
ways in the study it's surprising about
the gender is that we saw a bit of a
flop so the men are more interested in
making it home in time for dinner
whereas we saw an increase with women
who want that next bonus and that array
interesting and you know why women say
that because they're gonna use that
bonus and pay raise to bring takeout
home saying we want to get home for
dinner I would have thought that it
would have it would have been different
it was also interesting to see
Millennials have different ideas about
the ages of success I thought that was
interesting Catherine how does that work
yeah you know I think that as you know
as older people know that you're a
career with older people John's at the
table with older people your career
evolves and so what may have been really
important to you in your 20s that that's
going to evolve and what defines you and
what you see as success
I think absent flows and that it really
you realize that it's a journey and you
know many people in the Millennials
they're very interested in making time
for themselves
whereas the older generations we feat
see that they are motivated by giving
back by mentoring and volunteering what
about this idea of happiness meaning
when employees are happy how does it
affect the company's bottom line it
makes a huge impact if your employees
are happy they're contributing more
they're engaged and to think about it is
that if an employee isn't happy and so
they decide to leave the company what
happens is that then
company has to go recruit hire and train
someone else and that can get costly
alright so keep the people happy so
we'll stay in our job that's right yes
right we're all content thanks very much